hey you you've been a Muslim this whole
time remember exactly what you're
talking about Connor was trying to give
the whiskey yes yeah yeah yeah I don't
drink why don't you drink why don't you
drink you cannot say salaam alaikum and
congrat about whiskey
I went and I visited a Masjid uh maybe
three times he's a drunk alcohol guy or
something like that yeah yeah when
alcoholic someone drunk I talked nobody
cares about him oh right yeah
put him down gently he took a little nap
[Music]
great to see you
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
life is great we made it happen huh last
time over the web now we're live here
together in uh Sunny Tampa it's upon
Allah I'm here yeah I'm here I had to
drive all the way I love it though it's
a beautiful Center you got thank you for
alhamdulillah we got the future Dean
center now
alhamdulillah brothers and sisters as
you can see we've acquired the property
and we're getting right to work and with
your duas and support we can go ahead
and get the Masjid and meghadawa Center
up open and running in sha Allah imagine
every person that prays here gets
educated and guided to Islam here you'll
get a part of all those blessings and
rewards insha Allah what are you waiting
for brothers and sisters you're going to
leave it all behind anyway so go ahead
and invest in your Hereafter that's
Everlasting click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you lemon yeah
[Music]
you're one of the first here coming here
to uh hopefully you can take a picture
in your mind and remember soon when we
get it up and running yeah I'll have to
visit in about six months when you got
it uh really set up but so far I mean
it's it's the bones behind the place are
amazing
yeah it's going to come up so for those
that don't know you're uh your UFC
fighter you're with the UFC then you
left you went to EFC then you went to
another organization and now you're back
with the UFC no just straight back to
the U.S just straight back to the UFC so
I had one fight with eagle and then now
I'm back in the UFC yeah and uh I'll
make my my reappearance pretty soon okay
and you before that before coming to the
UFC we did an interview and you were
sharing you came out you're on ESPN and
you're gladly confidently letting the
world know shoot accepted submission to
the Creator not the creation Islam yes
yes yes which had been a long time
coming it had been a bit of a process
through that
um
people didn't even know that that I was
I had accepted Islam before I even got
cut from the UFC uh so
part of being cut actually renewed my
faith in Islam uh
I don't know how much of the story I can
kind of kind of share with you how much
of it I can kind of go back and tell
yeah because uh I haven't really done
many interviews or come out and share
the story but I do feel like it's
important for people that may be along a
similar path and and kind of looking for
the answers and looking for the the
meanings of life right
um it's actually the first interview in
person that you're talking about this
now for detail
yeah so uh
one time one time I had my fight with
Charles Oliveira yeah right I feel like
that's really the the fight that kind of
got this this this started it kind of
started a downward spiral yeah I tore my
knee during that fight
um which I might be like a little
different than some of the other guests
that you had on your show I've seen
other guests you've had
and they um they're a little more pure
in their Deen but me I I came from
straight sin
um so once I once I I tore my knee yeah
and I and I had the the surgery uh I was
introduced to the pain pills yeah and
then once you're introduced to the pain
pills then that kind of starts a
downward spiral through different drugs
and different things that that
seemed like the answer at the time they
seem like that's what you need in order
to to feel whole to feel like yourself
um
I went through that spiral for about a
year about a year and a half until my
birthday of the next year
um
and
once on my birthday and I really like
just spoke with God and I really prayed
and I really like looked for these
answers I had lost my last fight so I
just felt so lost like when you lose a
fight especially after you've had so
many years of winning you you just feel
kind of lost and hopeless uh
but but I spoke with God and this is
before I even became a Muslim and just
as clear as me and you were talking I I
felt like God told me hey you you've
been a Muslim this whole time you you
are a Muslim and I don't necessarily
feel like I revert it I just feel like I
I
woke up to the realization that that's
what I've been this whole time uh it
took a few weeks of me really being
introspective and me really kind of
clearing my system out of everything out
of the alcohol a lot of marijuana out of
the drugs out of whatever to really come
to that realization I went and I visited
a Masjid uh maybe three times without
even praying I just kind of sat in the
back and observed everybody uh it me and
you spoke a little off camera before and
I I just felt like a clearing of anxiety
like I didn't feel anxious at all uh
up until then the only time I didn't
feel anxious was during a fight yeah
during the fight I kind of cleared
myself but in being in the in a moss
like I didn't I felt like that's where I
was supposed to be uh
so I went to the imam's house I took my
shahada
and a week later
after doing that is when I got cut from
the UFC kind of blindsided me it was it
was unceremonious nobody kind of saw it
coming I didn't see it coming but that
kind of that's why I mean it it kind of
restored my faith in in okay maybe I am
I'm on the right path yeah and I told
this to my brother and he's like that
that doesn't make any sense like why
would why would you converting and then
something bad happening to you like mean
that you're on the right path it seemed
like you're on the wrong path to me but
in my heart I knew
nobody can really understand the the
conversations that you have with Allah
other than you I think
um and when that happened it kind of
renewed my faith like okay I'm
definitely on the right path uh and
where it gets interesting
I didn't I don't tell this to anybody
right nobody really knows that except me
and that Imam and a few people at the
mosque but nobody took pictures no but
nobody really knew
um and my brother Ali called me after I
got cut from the UFC he called me maybe
the next day or two days and he's like
oh it's terrible what they did to you
they cut you blah blah all this and he's
like I want to bring you into into
khabib's new organization which I had no
idea that could be was even starting an
organization he doesn't know that that
I've converted at this time
and uh I felt like that was another sign
like Ali was was
a a
way for for Allah to speak to me and
kind of give me a little bit of Hope in
in
tell me that I'm not just going to be
unemployed have no money the one door
closed but other doors start opening
exactly yeah and this other door just
happens to be through khabib and and
Habib has no idea that you accepted
Islam at this point no idea no no uh Ali
neither
um they don't find it that's Ali Abdul
Aziz right and Habib they have no idea
that you became a Muslim correct at this
point okay yeah
um they don't find out until after I
fight for him uh I fought in March I
signed with them in November fought for
him in March and you're not you weren't
like hey guys you know what uh I
actually accepted Islam there's like by
the way nothing yet no no I'm not the
type to kind of you know I'm more of an
introverted person so I don't I don't
just uh I don't just tell my business
like that for no reason
um
but you know he's kind of known me
through the years yeah and I I I've
always had respect for ali
um and I I think just as me being who I
am he he that's why he did it without
even knowing that that I had converted
at the time
well so at what point did they find out
um maybe a year and a half later not not
a year and a half uh about a year about
a year later was it from the ESPN or was
it from you guys talking privately how
did it come out it was maybe two months
before I announced it on ESPN uh I was
at the Masjid I had been going on
Fridays my brother Saeed had had took me
to to amasit in in Boca
um and I took a picture with somebody
there uh you know just as a fan kind of
coming up and asking for a picture he
saw that picture he called me on the
phone it was like you're you're Muslim
like I didn't even I had no idea he's
like oh okay now I really now we're
really brothers now I really can help
you
um and uh yeah that's how that's how you
found out and then I made the
announcement on ESPN what was the Habib
and Ali's uh reaction to that they they
were shocked
um they were shocked that that I was
Muslim for that long yeah
um but super welcoming super welcome as
with as with most Muslim people he was
he was super welcome come in and just
kind of happy that I was finally on on
this side of the fence wow so we were
talking about earlier how your first
exposure to Islam was through the Nation
of Islam and at that point you were very
young and many people confuse Orthodox
Real Islam with the Nation of Islam so
you kind of went away you didn't want to
have part and taken that but now you got
to see people like Malcolm X Muhammad
Ali who are also with the nation they
left the nation and they came to the
true Islam and now you are connecting
directly with your creator through Islam
the way Jesus did Moses did all the
prophets they did Islam many people
don't know that that's just completely
submitting your will to the creative
heavens and earth
tell me um you said you had such a
welcoming experience from the Muslim
Community how about other UFC fighters
about other peers how did they go ahead
and react to your decision uh a few guys
that that I actually fought before yeah
um which I'm not sure if he's if he's uh
made the announcement yet so I won't say
his name but uh a guy that I fought many
years ago
um and I had beat him and he he sent me
a direct message on on Instagram and
he's like man that's that's that's
amazing that you actually converted in
in your we're brothers now
um and you know you you you kind of you
make friends with some of the guys that
you fight but uh me and him we didn't
never see eye to eye uh so for him to
reach out to me and kind of extend his
hand was was
it was amazing it was like okay so this
was somebody who's on a different
competing team or somebody who you
wouldn't expect to go ahead and maybe it
was somebody I didn't expect to be
Muslim at all you did oh so you didn't
even I didn't know he was Muslim I had
no idea he was Muslim yeah
um and and then he sent me that message
and I was like oh okay wow that's
awesome yeah who was the fighter who
just fought uh helped me along with
these names he's also Brazilian was he
also a Muslim yeah Alex Perez yeah
yes yes I think he's Muslim he's Muslim
I think so yeah yeah but uh he's from
like a tribe in Brazil I don't know he's
scary he's scary so I don't I wouldn't
answer no questions but after you we
talked about this I just touch upon this
uh because Joe Rogan uh he was also you
know praising how the UFC uh many of the
people from Dagestan and this part of
the the world you know committed
discipline discipline pray fight God you
know what I mean all these distractions
like you know drugs alcohol late night
parties all that stuff that's like it's
not happening you know what I mean is
Islam helping you in this aspect also
like we talked about earlier that it was
kind of difficult the waking up for
fudger in the morning but then you have
like the Tony Robbins of the world and
they've done studies how you know
getting up at this time will set you
straight for the rest of the day you
know to be
um productive and whatnot are you seeing
like the wisdom are you seeing
absolutely you're training also regimen
Clarity of mine you know just getting up
at this early stage and yeah the
discipline and Beyond it and then also
when I was when I was kind of taking my
introspective time to to look back on my
life the last 30 years I noticed like
when I was that was at those discipline
moments that's when I always had my
biggest success so I looked back on my
fight uh with with Gregor Gillespie yeah
when I fought him in in New York uh when
I looked back on that on that camp I
noticed how early I was waking up uh how
I didn't drink alcohol at all before
then where some fights I would to be
honest I would be drinking through
throughout the camp
um even throughout the campus even
throughout the camp in in that fight in
particular
I was on such a mission to to kind of
re-establish myself as a top Contender
yeah that that I was so disciplined in
in
that fight was really the first time
that I that I postulated without knowing
that that's what I was doing
so so I've got a younger brother right
uh he's in prison right now
um at the time he was in he was in the
county jail and he was uh given a plea
deal against some charges that really
were kind of trumped up against them
that I wanted him to fight against yeah
and I remember being in my coaches uh
uh office when he gave me the call and
he's like bro like I'm I'm just I'm
having a hard time like I I is this can
be too much I'm just going to take the
plea deal
and I kept trying to beg him like don't
do it don't do it fight against you you
can win you don't give up these years of
your life
um I remember hanging up the phone with
them and I literally just dropped to my
knees and
I like
I basically posturate it without this is
way before I I'm I'm thinking about
converting I don't even know what what
Islam is at this point like you said I'm
still thinking it's it's the nation it's
it's black Supremacy it's it's all these
things that it means not the unity and
the peace and the love yeah but when I
sat there and and I just had a
conversation with god and I just spoke
with with laying down
um he told me that I needed to fight and
that ended up being one of the best
fights in my career and it it kind of
reinforced my my feelings behind like
you said like the the discipline and
everything that Islam teaches
that's what made that fight so great for
me
it wasn't
necessarily just my ego or that I was
bigger or stronger or anything like that
it was it was my discipline towards
towards staying true to myself and true
to God and and kind of following that
that voice uh in the moments when I when
I didn't follow that voice the the
results weren't nearly as spectacular
but I was surprised when you were saying
that even during training camp you have
uh not just yourself but many fighters
they do that they'll drink yeah yeah
yeah were you on the stage was that you
on the stage when it was Habib and Conor
were you in the uh
you remember that I remember exactly
what you're talking about Connor was
trying to give the whiskey yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know it's showing the
boss's birthday I I'm not understanding
yeah
happy birthday
why don't you drink why don't you drink
parties get my backwards boy I think
it's gonna be long night for him
ah yes oh Lord save me that's
thank you sir do we get an official
prediction on the fight yeah you cannot
say salaam alaikum and congrats about
whiskey
and you brought the whole open bottle on
top of the stage yeah was that his he
was trying to promote his whiskey and uh
I think there was a bit of that and
there was a bit of he really actually
liked the drink yeah he really did drink
and so he was yeah he's in he's about to
have the fight of his life yeah he's
drinking yeah he's drinking Habib what
was Habib saying like he's a drug
alcohol guy or something like that yeah
yeah he can say whatever you want when
alcoholic someone drunk guy talk nobody
cares about him we just leave him alone
ignore him and when we go to the cage we
will see who gonna talk
oh
[Applause]
um yeah that's it's just the the reality
of the situation especially when you're
when you're young and you kind of going
off momentum and and you feel uh
unbeatable Unstoppable and like you can
do whatever you want were you at one
point supposed to fight Connor
uh at one point yeah yeah yeah you think
that can ever happen I think so I think
it's still uh I think it's still out
there just depends on
there's there's a multitude of factors I
think it's timing more than anything is
he gonna fight soon at all Conor is he
lined up from what I've heard from what
I've heard he he'll come back at the end
of the year uh I'll come back in July
he'll come back here same division from
what I'm hearing that he wants to go to
170 so yeah okay yeah I'm permanently
170. yeah
yeah that would be a great fight one day
yeah one day Connor and uh Kevin Lee huh
yeah yeah being a lot of
it'll be a different me though I think
he'll he'll he'll uh he'll get a
different version of myself
so uh this is um this is something
that's truly um fascinating I've
interviewed so many different people and
just to see uh the more clarity of life
when people figure out the purpose of
life you know now they have structure
and discipline and your family now how
about uh family so you have some people
reach out but how's your family taken to
you accepting Islam um my mom right away
was overjoyed she was she was you know
she she's a devout Christian yeah
um we've spoken many times on on what
that means necessarily uh but
she's been this way for her entire life
um
but she was just Overjoyed that that
just brought me closer to God she told
me like I've just been waiting on
something to to bring you close to God
uh and she said if this is the way then
this is the way and she's she's uh one
thousand percent behind it um the rest
of my family is too I think they just
they aren't as as educated on it
um and I'm not necessarily the person to
to speak on things that I don't know
right I will always speak on my
experiences and and what I've seen with
my own two eyes uh but I'm not somebody
who pretends to know the answers to
anything
um so I I think some of my family
members it's a little harder for them to
come around but uh we've kind of always
all believed in God
um it's just we believed in God without
a a structure behind it
um and honestly Christianity doesn't
provide that structure wow
um we I've got some people in my family
that there there's a Baptist preacher
that's in my family
um and there's just no structure behind
it I don't I don't really think
Christianity means anything anymore I
think it you can pretty much do whatever
and and find a verse to to
to justify it yeah um so there's no
discipline there's no nothing while
you're reminding me I just interviewed a
very nice brother his name is Wilfredo
he was with the MLB the um baseball
league and Major League Baseball league
and he was sitting where you are and he
was one of the people responsible he was
organizing worldwide protests to get
Andrew Tate out of jail okay and they
just so I believe this is my opinion I
believe because of his work I believe
that they released Andrew Tate wow he
was possibly a means of the happening
because Andrew Tate's court date was
coming the protest was was coming up I
believe on the
2011 they released them on the 23rd and
so you would think like they're going to
get a lot of negative press you know
what I mean they got worldwide coverage
on these protests anyways the reason I
bring him up
he was actually talking about exactly
what you just said he was a Christian
he's got Jesus on his um tattooed he
talks about having the Bible in his back
pocket and he talks about how there was
no structure also what you're saying
like how how to you know worship God how
did things probably the all of the
things laid out like Islam does so
exactly what you're saying so many
Christians this is just one of them well
just with recently he was a Muslim now
and he's saying the exact same thing
we're seeing this and how many now
people are listening to you and they're
also out there now and hopefully God
willing they can go ahead and not just
follow how you do the takedowns and how
you throw a jab or a cross but they can
look into uh the way of life that's
bringing you peace and Solace now and
discipline and everything else your
connection with your creator Islam yeah
yeah yeah that's incredible yeah I don't
yeah I think the the ways of of
Christianity have gotten so skewed and
so uh kind of Lost in Translation almost
that it's it's easy to kind of get some
into the into evil it's easy to kind of
get pulled away from it because there's
nothing there's no anchor anchor kind of
holding you to it uh I mean they speak
about the prophet Jesus but they don't
really speak about like how he lived in
in who he was and what he did on a
day-to-day basis uh which when I look
into it when I when I do my research he
lived like a Muslim lives you know when
you when you see
obviously you can't see pictures of them
there there are no no pictures but when
you see depictions of them it's it's
always a as a Muslim uh and when you see
any of the the writings that he said
from his own mouth uh are some of the
same words that Muslims say uh in in
Arabic it's not even in English that
they've translated over and over again
so I think if uh if if Christians kind
of
stuck to to the teachings of Jesus it
would lead them to the teachers of Islam
as as
um ironic as that is I'm so happy you
brought this up because this is this is
something that many uh a majority of
Christians don't know the love that we
have for Jesus believing that he was a
Muslim translated one who submitted to
the will of God we believe that he was
the Messiah the translated Christ and
I'll ask you some things uh more on
Jesus and not and for an audience to
know obviously you're a new Muslim you
know taking baby steps learning as we go
along so if there's anything that's um
that's not clear we can go ahead and you
know iron out through it but but that's
uh there's a whole chapter named after
his Blessed Mother Maryam Mary and now
Jesus your relationship to Jesus now
people will think like oh he accepted
Islam you know what I mean he's lost
Jesus went away how is your relationship
with Jesus now knowing who he really was
what his message was it's the same
message of Islam calling people not to
worship him so but God so when people
hear this when your family member your
mother was a Christian that hold on I
love I actually love Jesus it's a tenant
of Faith to believe and love Jesus as a
messenger not as a literal Son of God or
a God how does this play into it when
you share these things yeah me it's
funny you say that because me and my mom
was just talking about this a few weeks
ago uh yeah and and I told her my it
actually strengthens your respect for
Jesus that that he was just a man just a
person uh he didn't create the the
heavens and the earth I mean look how
far these Heavens have reached when you
look through a telescope I mean you how
can a person in this type of Flesh
create something like that
um but but it strengthens my respect for
them because I know the the battles that
he's gone up against uh of sin and the
fact that he could come out and and
influence so many people throughout
history and throughout time and and for
thousands of years uh it strengthens
your respect for him and and your love
for him so I don't think me being a
Muslim changed that at all or Changed My
Views towards Jesus or change my views
towards even really not even change my
views towards Christianity
um I I have certain views about things
that they allow but not not towards the
people themselves uh let's shift now
um even though they've done studies
where when you talk about God and you
talk about these topics there's was The
God Spot things light up you know you
hear the spiritual side come out this is
good but we'll take us time out from it
we'll go back to also something I love
talking about because I I've been I've
been uh training for a long time too
I've been kind of away from everything
you know what really uh like most
Muslims when I started to watch some of
the the um bouts more was for when I saw
my cousin was like you got to see this
guy
um this Muslim guy I had no idea it was
Habib okay I didn't care about you know
much of the fighting and that and
whatnot but when I saw him go ahead and
finish his fight and take a time out to
be like it's not me it's the Creator and
he would humble himself and he made the
sajdah I was like that's what really
drew me to to him you know what I mean
so I started watching a little bit and I
got more up to speed and that someone
asked you back on this um there was a
fight what's your uh opinion now
you know Hicks and Gracie obviously this
was a legend right accent hoist that's
who I got my blue belt from I also um
met I trained with KRON he visited our
Academy a long time ago hixson's son
he's fighting I think tomorrow isn't he
yeah he's coming back I think right you
know he's been gone for like three years
now please forgive me ahead of time
because I know there's some sometimes
there's like you mentioned a name and
this is like okay that's my enemy or
here what now no no no no no no so yeah
it was a competition so I might say
someone that maybe there's a beef so
forgive me I don't know different camps
and stuff so I'm just I'm throwing out
some snake I know the people and whatnot
and so what do you think now KRON coming
back he took he had a a really tough
fight when he fought last time I think
it's been four or five years he's coming
back who did he fight last I I kind of
could he cron cron Gracie
Cub Swanson okay yeah I'm trying to
remember that fight
um
yeah I know it's been a few years since
he since he came back have you do you
know so he's part of the Nate Diaz and
uh okay okay the the kind of trains over
in California yeah
um honestly I don't know that much about
him to be honest what did you think
speaking of this what did you think of
just recently you had the fight was it
Nate or Nick and then oh right yeah
oh yeah
dude
yeah uh
Nate Nate's claiming self-defense and
I'm gonna connect this to Islam and I
kind of I can kind of see his argument
there you know when you see uh Jake
Shields is the one that I know that that
you know yeah Jake Shields a friend of
mine okay um so he kind of came out in
in defense broke it down yeah I could
kind of see why I mean just because
we're we're we're professional fighters
he's still a human and he knows if a guy
lands a punch on you especially when you
don't expect it he can knock you out
right then and there exactly so you you
have to be able to defend yourself I
mean one of the first things about
martial arts it kind of teaches you is
you got to respect that man even if you
don't know him even if his name isn't as
big even if he he's never even fought
before uh I think Nate showed him the
proper respect and if that was say if
that was Kamara Usman or if it was Leon
Edwards or or somebody who poses a real
threat to him coming up to him in the
same way I think he would handle it the
same way
because you have to stay out of you have
your Zone you have your space and in
self-defense you know you can't let
somebody come into your area because you
can get Sucker Punch you're going to get
hit so he was putting his hands up right
blocking yeah making sure and then what
happened from there the camera kind of
shifted you couldn't see but you can see
he started off with his hands right he's
blocked he's you know and it's funny
because you know one of my first kind of
things that that put me on the map was
was uh hitting Michael keosa when he ran
across the stage at me uh and I had to
explain it to Dana like why why would
you do that because there's a certain
zone between me and you and we know that
as men once you cross that that line and
sometimes the the barriers and uh
invisible yeah you know so for me and
him it was the halfway point of the
stage yeah so once he crosses that
halfway point you know you're on my my
side I have the right to defend myself
uh which in Nate's case yeah he had the
right to defend himself if he's putting
his arms up and the guy came within our
reach and not be friendly about it yeah
then you yeah you're going to get hit
and he helped them out you put them down
gently you took a little nap I don't
know if it was gentle yeah yeah
but yes
I can see him getting away with it a
little bit you know I think he should he
should be able to defend himself yeah
for sure and there's so many people
there's so much stuff going on what are
you gonna do and then the guy probably
may be trying to make a name for him so
he's in that zone exactly but that was
one of my famous things before I mean
not uh not famous but yeah well famous
that's what I'd like to do back in my
day on the street as soon as somebody
comes to me and he's in my face the
first thing had butt hey but yeah yeah
this is the streets this is this is an
MMA fight you know yeah uh so even even
the the letting them down gently I think
he did right by dropping them uh because
you you he has to stay on his feet you
know this is a 200 pound man that we're
talking about in dead weight if he goes
down to the ground to let him down
gently you don't know if the guy next to
you is coming up and gonna sucker sucker
kick you in the head or something you
know you you gotta you gotta defend
yourself was that were they was that
like a party going on or something it's
like I have no idea I think it was Mardi
Gras so people just kind of partying the
street yeah but but and then it's it's a
lot going on it's yeah that Salon
protects you from all this
Islam safeguards you helps you to be
home at a decent hour explain it to me
explain it because you know a lot in the
Quran says don't come near Zina right so
now uh anything that can lead you in to
a situation that now for instance
there's a nightclub a Muslim really
standing in front of a nightclub there's
alcohol even sitting at a table where
there's alcohol these are the things
that now Allah wants to protect you so
now you don't fall into right it's not
just like when I just quoted this Ayah
this is uh don't come near Zina Zina is
fornication adultery and that so that's
why it's forbidden to be with the
opposite gender man to be alone with a
woman there's a saying a wise man said
leave a man alone honest man alone with
a a suitcase money money be safe leave
him alone with a good looking woman you
don't know what can happen you know what
I'm saying so that's why the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessing me upon him
and said when a man is alone with a
woman shaytan is the third shaytan is
the third you get it the devil's a third
because now things can end up happening
right so you don't even want to be alone
with someone who's not your wife or
whatnot because things can transpire
things can happen you saw what the whole
metoo movement right the boss alone with
the lady and then all these charts
you're even as a Muslim you're trying to
keep a distance you know keep yourself
keep it respectful keep it now same
thing when it comes to other things you
know what I mean because you can fall in
Temptation can hit you know now you end
up in the white club now you end up
taking a drink now you're off you know
to me can I ask you a question if so is
it wrong for you to sit in that
nightclub then with in not partake
wouldn't that be kind of a a test
against your your your your your faith
in a test against your your discipline
um say it again to be able to sit there
in the nightclub have everybody else
around you drink and you not take a
drink let me let me give you an example
yeah so we have different stages people
have different stages of discipline
right but Islam when it comes is general
rules
for all you know what I mean like some
people will say because alcohol is
prohibited correct that's something
that's well known someone says but I can
handle it you know what I mean maybe the
other one person his level is is
different but it just takes that one
time that you end up drinking too much
and now you end up uh causing an
accident you killed the other person
drunken driving no no I mean I mean for
you not to take a drink yeah so so now
now we go to that now for example this
I'll give you an example let's say you
have someone gifted you a or you bought
you work so hard to buy uh uh I didn't
even know this car before until I
interviewed uh Andrew Tate uh the the
Bugatti oh okay I didn't even know when
I was talking to him I was like what
kind of car is the Bugatti so let's say
bugatti because that's like I think uh
five hundred thousand dollars I think
it's like a million over a million yeah
so I asked people I said look you got a
Bugatti would you leave it in a bad
neighborhood with the keys open and the
windows down would you would you no no
you would do that right of course so our
Iman is more precious our faith is more
precious maybe one time second time
third time you know you're in the club
or you're somewhere and you're
discipline but then that it just takes
that right honey or whatever you want to
call it it comes and that's it you lose
now you lose yourself you know and and
things spiral out of control so
prevention is better than chasing the
Cure you know what I'm saying so we know
what happens in these places the Angels
aren't in these places so it's the best
to avoid you want to be it's a different
feeling when you're in the Masjid when
you're around people reminding you and
you won't find people like bib or other
people discipline in this area but you
know I know you know I come from that
lifestyle I know and it took me a while
to go ahead and to this is my cell but
it was different even just being in this
atmosphere without being drunk yeah
that's that's you know what I'm saying
yeah it's like you're talking a
different language yeah that's
definitely true yeah yeah I've visited a
few since my conversion yeah and being
there Stone sober is it's it's different
isn't it's born to be honest with you
you don't even want to be there maybe
you're Iman maybe you're just not having
the best at that time and then you're
just like things are going wrong and
everything is set right the music it's
not having an effect on you the Honey's
there you know the the drink is there
that's all it takes like that now you
lost the car because you left it you
didn't protect your Iman yourself you're
in an atmosphere that's not conducive to
your to your growth and your spiritual
now you just lose yourself you see what
I'm saying okay but is it not more
reward for someone who can avoid who can
have all those Temptations put in front
of them and not indulge if you're in a
situation that you catch yourself
something happens and whatnot and you
push away of course you're going to get
rewarded because you know by probably by
now if not you know when a person does
one evil a bad deed is counted as one
um against him but if a person was even
they were thinking about doing it and
they restrained they didn't even do it
they still they get rewarded for that
right right right right and then the
reward is 10 to 700 times
um can be for the good deeds that
someone does right and then just add on
top of that when someone does a sin the
angel on the right writing holds back
from even writing that giving the time
for the person to repent look at the
mercy the law is not trying to just
punish you he's the most loving merciful
but this is for us to go ahead and to
really you know reflect but we don't
want to we don't want to uh as Muslims
live in between fear and hope we don't
want to play you know what I mean it's
not about love love love there's the
Hellfire also it's real you know what I
mean we don't want to die imagine dying
in a place like yeah no what I mean I
see what you see what I'm saying you
don't want it so it's the risk the the
the harms outweigh you know the Harms
outweighed any kind of benefits yeah can
I answer your question yeah yeah and
again you know step by step a lot of
times it took me a while also it took me
I was uh I had a part uh you know
promoting a whole different world there
I know it took me a while to to to
adjust I feel the the hard part is other
people and other people that you may
love you know whether it be your
brothers yeah whether it be you know
even like my wife she's not necessarily
a Muslim I know so it's that that
becomes the hard part of it I understand
yeah it's challenges of coming up um but
um tell me um when you are these some of
the things like I was asking you off
camera like now are you starting to see
in one aspect the wisdom behind some of
the injunctions you know some of the
things because there's a direct uh verse
where Allah is talking about there might
be some things that you dislike but it's
good for you and there might be some
things that you just like but it's bad
for you you don't know Allah knows you
know what I mean so have you seen that
in your life where there's some things
that you you know you had to give up or
anything and then later down the line
now you're seeing like okay I see the
wisdom yes yes yeah and and I've
actually made Dua a few times to to give
me that wisdom beforehand but I don't
feel like that's how it always comes out
sometimes it's it's after you know after
you've done something and then six
months or two a year later then then
you'll kind of see the consequences of
it whether it be good or bad uh that's
why I just kind of always trying to stay
on this path now yeah because I I just
feel if you're if you're on the right
path if you're on the path of Islam then
then
[Music]
the consequences will be good
um because you don't necessarily we I
don't think us as humans had that that
wisdom you know like you said only Allah
knows the the entire plan we kind of see
bits and pieces of it you know I can
kind of see what's right in front of me
I could I could see the experience that
I've gone through or what I've had now
but I can't see the experience of my
future so I I just have to to pray and
stay steadfast that all my decisions
will be the right one to lead me to the
right path when you're going through
those challenges you were talking about
that's that's a huge epidemic of the
painkillers opioids all of this stuff
that's happening you know and then that
that sets things people up for other
drugs you know that so you experience
that now imagine how would that be if
you're still hanging you want to help
people out of that but if you're if a
person is going to help themselves if
you're constantly around the group of
people who are just you know uh
entertaining these things and they just
use it casually it's gonna that's gonna
eventually uh yeah that's though those
are it's a bigger problem than and I was
even expecting you know I kind of always
I kind of always knew it was a problem
right as growing up you kind of you just
I I know I've seen my uncles I've seen
other people kind of go through it and I
just knew to stay away from it but I
didn't realize how powerful it was until
you you're you're kind of forced to take
it yeah you know when you when you have
a major surgery and then uh it was
Percocets first that they gave me and
before my experience with painkillers
was like an ibuprofen where you don't
really feel anything you know you take
it and it's okay I don't even remember
but you take the a certain type of
painkiller and you like oh no this this
it changes your your entire uh
experience of the world even
um
where it makes you feel like okay this
is good like that it's such a tricky
it's such a uh what's the word I'm
looking for like
it can just blind you to the reality of
the situation until it gets too far out
of your grass
um which is what I feel like it did for
me
inshallah didn't lead me too far before
I was able to catch a grip on myself
um which luckily I had fighting that
kind of that kind of did that for me if
I didn't take uh a fight in in August my
last UFC fight if I didn't take that
fight I wouldn't have made these
realizations but me taking that fight
and being on the the painkillers and
being on the stimulants at the same time
um
of the fight doesn't lie to you yeah I I
I'm in love with fighting because it's
it's like the purest form of your
expression that you can have uh and it
doesn't lie to you and I think sometimes
even if you're a smart person you can
kind of make up stories and you can kind
of do things in your own head
um but at the end of the day the reality
of the fight will always kind of bring
it to you so me going through that fight
made me realize like all these drugs are
are really sending me down the wrong
path it's not getting me to to where I
need to be wow and was it was it really
hard did you have to go through how much
of a detox or how much yeah how time how
much time did it take to get off of this
it took me about four weeks yeah
um starting from my birthday which was
uh beginning of September yeah until
like the end of October yeah middle of
October when I made uh shahada
um yeah about about four weeks you just
said something here maybe some people
maybe uh Dana White's tuning in or some
other UFC fighter somebody and you say
shahada so I just want to go ahead and
just
remove the mystery from it so once
there's five pillars in Islam one of
them is to go ahead and when someone
professes this they say the shahada the
testimony that there's nothing worthy of
worship except the creator of the
heavens and earth and Arabic Allah
Aramaic coincidentally is Jesus spoke
Aramaic so he would say Allah also Allah
and that Muhammad is the messenger final
messenger and this would include all the
preceding messenger Jesus Moses all the
ones that came before it so that's
something that you said to come into
Islam what was it when you when you
accepted Islam when you took your
shahada
what was that feeling like what was it
that finally did it for you that you
were just like you know what uh I'm
gonna because I've been in situations
where you can it's such a blessing it's
it's something that Allah opens your
heart to because someone can be shown
all the proofs and evidences and Islam
has so much of it but still it's just
not meant to be something Allah didn't
open their heart but what was it that
finally clicked with you that you just
you're like I'm ready I I I wanted I
need to do this
was there one thing or just I I think it
was my experience inside the master yeah
I think it was my experience of of
sitting in in the Masjid and and not
even taking
you know I I wasn't uh praying or I
didn't actually come into it but but it
was my experience of seeing the people
through it yeah
um
it was that and then like I said me me
being fired from the UFC after that
that's that kind of really renewed my
faith and it made me pray even more
um but yeah I think that's the the
that that's the point where I was like
okay this is the path for me when I
walked in and I didn't feel like anxious
I didn't feel like oh I want to get out
of here like oh I want to you know
throughout my whole life that's kind of
how I had been just kind of going
through life uh but without that I knew
I was on the right path did you see any
statues Idols icons no nothing like that
no no just just kind of bare minimum
stuff which for me was like you know
when you when you come from Detroit it's
the flash it's the bling it's the
everything that kind of attracts people
right but uh I'm like how can all these
people and it's it's about a good two
three hundred people I'm like how can
all these people be so happy and kind of
peaceful and and being bare you know
Bear's love is like you said there was
no giant statue there was no you know
there was no gold medals or anything
sitting up on it and people still
they came there religiously has anybody
cut like discreetly or have you sent
somebody who uh because as human beings
I mean most people have a void they
they're they're searching but they're
kind of like lost you know they don't
have Direction has anybody kind of
hinted to you or anybody that you
actually yourself invite us to come with
me come to Jim I come to the Mars come
you know see uh they're seeing this
peace with you they're seeing you know
this you now taking a new turn in life
and they want some of that
um there hasn't been anybody yet yeah uh
are you open today yeah absolutely one
of your peers someone's you train with
they say man I want to visit the mosque
with you right absolutely welcome to
come with you yeah in Shalom one day
someone someone will but I I haven't uh
had that experience yet I think that'll
be the next kind of transformative
phases to is to allow somebody else to
experience it and kind of almost
experience it again through their eyes
yeah
um yeah I I look forward to teaching my
son and I look forward to teaching some
of my family but um I haven't felt that
yet misconceptions there's a lot of them
a ton of them there's been so many books
written people who opponents of Islam
you know it's become a big business
bashing Islam so how is that has
anything affected you in this way so I'm
kind of a skeptic right I'm kind of I I
see something in automatically my my
first thing I've always been one to go
against the grain yeah so I feel like if
everybody's going this way I'm gonna try
and go this way
um and even with Islam right there
there's two billion people that that on
this planet right now that that are uh
that are Muslims in in part of me
towards it is like okay there has to be
there's got to be something here that
that I can kind of go against so when
I'm reading the Quran and I'm reading
everything and and even things that I'm
hearing I'm seeing videos I'm seeing all
this stuff
there was nothing that I could point to
to say
no that's
that doesn't make any sense there was
nothing that I could ever point to that
that I could refute or that I could kind
of go against or either I get logic my
way out of
um that I found in a lot of other
religions that this one I just
and I couldn't and and I didn't
I don't say that to please other Muslims
I don't say that to please other people
I I just say that because
that has been my experience and and
that's what
really just to please God and really
just to please a lot like
that's just the truth of the matter
I can't at least in myself when I when I
read the book and I and I hear and I
listen to the book I can't understand uh
Arabic obviously
um
but I can't find anything in any English
translation that I can refute I try yeah
I've never seen somebody else do it
either yeah I've tried to look up
Skeptics of it
I can't find it wow uh let's shift a
little bit uh we we were talking about
nutrition you know now you're coming up
in weight and how long have you been
taking nutrition serious like what do
you like to eat in the morning and you
just eat anything just to bulk up or
because I was like I told your life I
thought you were much smaller man you're
just like you're pretty big yeah uh you
know yeah it's been about really since
since I had left the UFC and when I
started bulking up even more yeah
um and through my knee surgeries and
stuff like that I kind of had to take
nutrition super seriously yeah
um
I I I do and I don't I allow myself some
some breathing room yeah I do allow
myself
some time to relax because sometimes I
feel like you you can almost take it a
little too too serious if that makes
sense and and you can kind of stress
yourself out about certain things
um but I I make sure everything that I
eat is is
whole if that makes sense like like
nothing processed really yes okay um
Whole Foods and and really I've been
training and I've been fighting for so
long I've been fighting for 12 years now
so I kind of have been through many
different weight cuts and in many
different diets where I understand my
body
um I don't really listen to many other
people on their um recommendations for
food because we're in a different body
um some things I've experimented with in
terms of food and knowing what agrees
with me and what doesn't and I feel like
I found a good balance uh but I don't I
I kind of refrain myself from giving
other people advice on it because I
could tell you something that works for
me that doesn't work for you at all yeah
only thing I could say is just to find a
good balance and things
and Whole Foods Whole Foods always yeah
that part I can't yeah I learned his
term for my nutritionist uh eat real
food avoid this is like just the white
Bell level real basic and I stick by
that myself eat real food avoid fake
food fake food is anything that comes
with a list of ingredients that you need
a chemistry biology degree to pronounce
I I stay away from that and I've seen a
big yeah I mean this body has been
around for hundreds of thousands of
years right before people were able to
to create these foods and labs and
um I I think the the the the Most
Blessed people
we're eating simple things I think
simple is is always better than than the
convoluted how's the eggs eggs steak
Yeah sweet potatoes avocados do you feel
good with your body avocados I don't
really not really yeah not not avocados
for me liver but
you know I've been onto the organ Meats
lately organ Meats yeah yeah yeah liver
uh
I'm kind of you seem like a little shy
to yeah yeah because these are the most
healthiest foods it is it is but but for
some people it's kind of like they
immediately yeah it's a visceral type of
reaction but just the most nutritious
food it is and you know
one of the things Detroit is known for
is is it chilly right Detroit chili yeah
uh Coney dogs chili dogs stuff like that
um I found out in college that that the
secret ingredient to the chili is beef
heart it's actually a mixture of beef
heart and ground beef which I never
really knew uh but my mom said that that
was one of the things that she ate when
I was uh when she was pregnant with me
yeah she ate a lot of chili fries and a
lot of uh and apparently there's a lot
of beef heart in there it's visceral you
know kind of uh the organs of the animal
which organ Meats do you particularly
like most uh kidney's pretty good yeah
yeah
um how about liver
I've had duck liver a few times duck
liver duck liver is great yeah dog liver
tastes great whatever they say is the
most nutritiously nutritiously dense
food like if you want the most bang for
your buck yeah yeah I feel like you got
to cook it right though you know some
people already livers and onions in them
what about raw yeah I've never tried
that never tried raw no you have yeah
you tried Raw Liver oh yeah oh yeah okay
some raw liver with my brother
does her body good alhamdulillah
it's not bad huh well that is good it's
good cows delivered uh mainly uh lamb or
cow also yeah cow yeah wow okay your
Braverman at me yeah
see it's it's a mindset if you know like
you're
um I mean if you're persuaded the
evidence is there that
um okay this is the most bang for your
buck and you're not just going to eat
something that's going to excite your
taste buds you're doing it because now
because like a lot of times you're
programmed you know because of all the
foods we eat convenient junk food fake
food but then you know you're told like
this is actually good for your body it's
nourishing your body it's prop I'm in
you know if it's good for me I'm in I'm
gonna you know they're trying to program
myself to eat that when you said sheep
and lamb liver I could I could see that
more yeah because it's probably less
processed and stuff but but cow liver
I'm not I'm not too sure about if it's
humanely raised animal mainly yes yes
exactly I like what you said not from
conventional no way no all right yeah no
okay I just want to make yeah I just
want to be clear about it yeah okay
hopefully when you you come up down um I
have we have uh some some land we got
some sheep and goats so oh usually have
you ever done it yourselves without an
animal prepared no I'll go I've never
step yeah you you yeah yeah you'll take
me oh yeah all right let's go yeah let's
go I'm excited for that now
I'll leave but I got the Sheep ready
I got ready to go
so so this is that's what I love so
we're talking about
the spirit the soul the heart many
people neglect this and they go down the
road of alcohol drugs and feeling trying
to fill that void you know if all these
things that just keep you empty don't
have you feel did you feel some kind of
did you feel some kind of void comparing
making a contrast before it was there
was that that void how did that feel and
now
what do you feel compared to back then
yeah I I feel like
I'm only 30 right yeah but I feel like
I've lived for a long time and
the first majority of my life was kind
of chasing Money Power Respect you know
those are the things that that I was
after growing up like that's all I
really was focused on
get more money get more power and then
people will respect you
um
and coming up through fighting I kind of
got those
but it didn't it didn't do anything for
me it didn't it didn't satisfy the the
oh the more I got the more the hunger
kind of came out
um
which can be
demoralizing a little bit it can be kind
of depressing when you you're like man I
got everything that I that I dreamed of
like I got the big contracts I got the
house and my mom's okay all right I did
all that all the stuff that I thought
was Gonna Fill Me Up Now now I just want
a bigger house now I just want the I
just want more of it
um
and it can just lead you on on this this
just dark path like you said the sex the
money the drugs the all that like
dark hole Yeah but but but when you get
on the the the right path which
honestly is a lot of tests through it
even
you know like I said I I got cut from
the UFC right after that so it's a lot
of uncertainty through that yeah
um
I feel like I was almost Stripped Away
of all those things you know people
start respecting me less
people start you know I didn't have as
much power
didn't have as much money all that but
I feel like God took those things away
from me so that I could really
feel love I could really feel
compassion Unity I can really feel a
sense of Duty
which which is a lot bigger than Chase
of money and power and and women you
know yeah uh a sense of Duty for one
that that every move that I make every
word that I speak everything that I do
is is in the words of Allah and it's
following that path that gives me a lot
more uh
feeling of of
fulfillment than any type of
money or any amount of money could ever
give me so yeah it's given me a lot more
substantial did it the Miracle of Life
that did that have an impact on you many
don't know you just had a son yeah right
he's five months five months not too
long ago he didn't exist that was but
now he's here
oh yeah yeah it's
I'm kind of you know I want to get back
to him right now yeah it's it's the best
thing in the world it's it's so amazing
I wish somebody you know people always
scared me into having kids for some
reason
um if if I can't give a message to
anybody is have some kids especially
when you're young man have some have
some kids it's it's so I feel if if I
would have had him
I wasn't the man yet I wasn't I wasn't
ready yet but I
I kind of yeah I wish I had him younger
even I would have been helped some man
also uh mature not just living for
yourself now responsibility and helps
you you know the completion of you
completing you in that way yeah and it
gives you just another sense of Duty you
know I think that's I think that's what
a lot of men are are missing
um I think that's where our world is
kind of going wrong a little bit is it
taking that Duty away from the man
um and you just feel so empty without
that you you I I truly think that you
need it
um and kids is just a built-in way to to
have it you know my son he needs to eat
he needs it I'm the one that that has to
provide it from him for him so just that
alone
if he's eating
the the rest of life is taken care of
what else am I do I have to worry about
I don't have I don't care about anything
else other than him being taken care of
yeah
it's that's the part that people don't
tell you about having kids I wish
someone did yeah a few more minutes
where we come to an end uh just your
your opinion on and I know this can be a
little bit controversial for some people
but you see it over the news you see men
because you're professional athletes so
this kind of goes with it you see some
men who identify as something else and
they're competing in sports for women
and they're winning right and it seems
like uh this is taken away from from the
women who are going into these Sports
and now they're being deprived because a
man is coming in yeah but he's not a man
so it's confusing now and he's winning
the triathlon the swimming competitions
yeah have you heard about these things
yeah yeah of course of course I have we
don't have to talk about it even in MMA
I mean yeah we can
um there are certain parts of it that
you do kind of you get nervous to talk
about it right because there's mobs of
people but it doesn't seem like you're
you're that type to like yeah I don't
really care too much about social media
or anything like that I care more with
what
and for other people too you know I want
to see other people do good I want to
see other people I want to see Society
Thrive yes and and this path that that
they're trying to go down of a man can
be a woman and you can you can kind of
give into these delusions and you can
you can
supplement these these mental illnesses
I mean that's let's be honest that's
what it is even if you ask the person
themselves they'll tell you I'm I'm
mentally ill something's wrong with me
um why do we these days buy into that
why do we say that that's good why are
we teaching children this why are we
sexualizing children
that's the
that's the craziest thing in the world
why is that okay why does anybody that's
that's an able-bodied adult feel like
it's okay to talk about a child's
sexual orientation sexual anything why
is it sex and children in the same
sentence
it's so mind-boggling to me that that
more people don't say how wrong this is
and so many people attack people who who
come out against it it's pure evil if if
sexualizing children isn't evil Then I
then I don't know what is I mean it's
the purest evil that I that I can think
of
um
and allowing people to to to do this and
allowing people to to main children and
and
give in to this stuff is is just it's
just wrong it's just flat out wrong it's
it's and a lot of we've been talking
about is Islam and you know things being
allowed and not allowed
and if we truly believe this is the word
of God and we know that this is the word
of God why would you not listen
to what God is telling you you you're
going to hear them and then look the
other way and say okay I'm gonna do what
I want to do
the most insane thing in the world to me
and I don't think
Earth has a big enough punishment for
people that that decide to do that
yeah and I think many people when they
see the the mob attacking a small group
attacking people who come out to say
look leave our children alone
do your thing in your bedroom keep that
over there to yourself but leave our
children alone right which should be
obviously but apparently it's not yeah
apparently it's not yeah I feel like
that should be the most basic obvious
thing you you have a right to defend
yourself you have a right to defend the
people that you love especially
defenseless people speaking about
children and the defenseless they don't
they don't know anything they only know
what we tell them and if we tell them
right out the back that it's okay if you
want to be a little girl if you if
you're a boy it's okay it's okay all
right yeah sure if you
it's it's it's so crazy and and even
when you hear the the arguments of oh
gender is a is a social construct many
things are a social construct we still
abide by them
this building that we are sitting in at
one point was a social construct we're
still here
why is that an argument I don't
understand if gender is a social
construct it
okay it's true
all right
I I don't understand any of the
arguments for this type of uh dysphoria
that a lot of people experience and it's
nice it's refreshing when you when you
have and like we start out talking about
Islam you know or even the Bible makes
this clear you know the Quran makes this
clear how God Almighty Allah created us
the man and the woman the man is not
like the woman you know these are this
is something that is from the beginning
of time right so people in position like
yours and others you know you can be the
person who even has strong feelings
against us but if you're silent then
what happens you know the voices of that
Minority become the majority and next
thing you know the kids are getting
sexualized right nobody stood up to
defend the little ones you know which
which I feel like is what we've done in
the last couple years uh the the strong
men who really kind of know right from
wrong and know their own experience and
are true to it we've kind of stayed
quiet
um and kind of let the let the monkey
he's run the zoo uh it's been it's been
a lot of that nobody's really
I'm not going to say nobody's had the
balls to stand up for it but
you see Piers Morgan talking a little I
don't know if you'll know Piers Morgan
he's the British uh yeah okay he's
talking up you can see him that's nice
yeah there there's a few people and I
feel like now we're finally starting to
to stand up for it because we're we're
just starting to see it's you if you let
people do to their own devices uh
someone who is evil who will kind of
take advantage of people uh will do that
and we we have a duty not to let that
happen yeah um and not just get devolved
into our own world which I feel like a
lot of a lot of men are doing right now
at least strong men you know we kind of
you know you you can be the the kingdom
of your own of your own forces around
you yeah
um and you can kind of get sucked into
that and forget about the greater
overall purpose of society which uh for
me I want to see Society Thrive for many
many generations and not just in the
next couple years do you feel that's
also part of uh being being a man being
someone who's courageous not just being
courageous to right in because it takes
a lot of courage to fight in this cage
but to go ahead and speak the truth
against that's actually harder to be
honest with you it's harder because
because sometimes you don't know
if you're if if how you're feeling now
is going to change in the future
um like I said fighting is it is what it
is it's a it's a moment it's a snapshot
of time but I think one thing that that
the internet is kind of teaching us is
is some of this stuff is going to live
forever
so it's it's kind of you you have to
make sure you're on the right path
before you say something because in the
next few years things could be different
and it could change so I think it's
actually more courageous when people
stand up and they speak it's it's more
courageous to do that than than to step
in a cage and fight and this is why one
of the reasons we do the the dean show
because it's out of the love uh we go
ahead and share this message and people
who are even going down these paths I I
truly believe it's because they don't
have the guidance of the Creator and
that that door is open for them too for
everybody you know because
he's the most loving the most merciful
so uh if you want to live a good
wholesome Pure Life uh you'll come to
the way of life that was real for the
creator of heavens and earth the way of
life that you're upon and that's
bringing that Solace and peace and
inshallah it continues to you keep
living it and you can be a good
inspiration and motivation for others
and what uh with closing now what advice
would you give for maybe a person who is
going down to straight the path also
maybe the loss to fight they lost the
battle whatever and now they're also
taking some of these uh pills and they
maybe even contemplating taking their
life whatever the case and they're just
tuning in now
and they're listening to you you know
and then they're they they've been
hearing the term Islam and whatnot and
you're they're a fan of yours and
they're they want to hear what advice
would you give them the only advice I
can give is just not to give up not to
give up to keep pushing keep pushing
don't don't give up uh
eventually Allah will will come to you
in whatever shape or form that that is
just don't give up don't don't Lose
Yourself don't don't
think just because you are this way
today that you're gonna be this way
forever I think you never know what's
going to happen
you you can't give up you you keep going
even if you gave up yesterday keep going
today and tomorrow and the next day and
the next day just don't don't give up
you not we never really know what this
world is gonna
gonna end for us but we know
if we if we can stay on the right path
that that eventually Allah's love will
will be there in the end beautiful any
other closing comments anything where
people can look you up
no not really no just get ready for my
fight and uh in July and I think
I kind of will let the the fight
be a be a representation of of who I am
at the moment
um that's why that's a lot of the
reasons why I've stayed shy of for
saying so much yeah I I want to show
everything through actions and then I'll
be able to speak
may Allah God Almighty bless you uh
inshallah
look at me as your older brother I'm
here for you to help you along your
journey anything you need I'm a phone
call away thank you and when we get down
here permanently we're not too far away
either so I shall look forward to having
you here back when we finish up
everything yeah I got to come back in
like six months once this place is it's
gonna be beautiful it's gonna be a nice
nice spot that you guys set up here yes
you're a blessing you too thank you so
much my brother I cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you are not yet
Muslim and you're tuning in to see what
these Muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the Quran go and
visit thedenshow.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you